[Applause]
you look beautiful
thanks for being here good too i know
[Laughter]
what's that you like this time i like
your tie well you can eat it after the
show
i know it does native starbursts that
have been glued together yeah
but thanks for being here thank you for
inviting me congratulations i haven't
seen you since you won
the golden globe uh for your role in the
closure that's been that's very exciting
it was it was fantastic and last year
you hosted the emmys and you were so
funny oh please you were hysterical it's
madness
no and let me tell you
you look so funny can i just say
something the pause before the audience
applauded was awkwardly long
she was like you were so funny the
crowd's like well i don't know
they were waiting i've seen better you
were so funny and i was in the most
uncomfortable dress and i was in the
front row and the only thing that kept
me going was you
because i lost two right but the golden
globe that's fantastic amazing yeah the
golden globes you know i'm curious about
something your career is of course going
very well
but this must be a little difficult your
your husband mr kevin bacon lives in new
york
with the kids this is a so you've got to
keep this relationship going long
distance that's got to be difficult
yeah it's hard you know but there's the
phone and there's
ichat ichat yeah is ichat you find that
better than the phone
yeah because you know you can see each
other and
let's just say i'm really grateful for
steven jobs right right he's kept my
marriage together
right is it everything that gets kinky
over i chat is that what you're
suggesting maybe
sometimes you know i don't think that's
what i think when they came up with a
computer they weren't that wasn't their
first thought
maybe it was their first time second
check right right let me tell you
because i mean i chat i mean
really what are people going to use that
but how hot and heavy can it get on
i chat i don't think it i mean i've
experienced that a little bit it doesn't
look like you can really be like
you know it doesn't look that exciting
to me oh you have to use your
imagination no it's good
though it's gotten better and better
okay maybe you don't have the right
camera
you just solved all my problems um
you uh you've been married now how many
18 years we're going on 19
19 in september wow when you
yeah oh yeah thank you look at that
immediate applause for that concept
um you uh was it love at first sight
when you and kevin matt what was
what were the circumstances of your name
we met doing um
a film called uh lemon sky which was do
you remember abc ameri
i mean pbs network abc no no no i'm
sorry i remember them back in the day
pity what happened to abc uh pbs yes
american playhouse anyway it doesn't
matter they did these small
films and they did a film called lemon
sky and we met
and the first time i met him um actually
i was 12 and he was much older
he was in a play but that was a long
time ago but we met doing this oh good
my god i thought you were
that almost took a horrible turn yeah we
fell in love when i was 12 and got
married
in the ozarks um
no but when we met it was instant lust
on his part he says it was
instant lust and for me it was instant
not so interesting how old were you
really when this happened no i was i was
22.
okay good good uh and and you met and he
so what did he do to pursue you i like
to hear those stories
it's actually
no i'm just curious how is he suave and
cool about i know what happened was he
kept inviting the whole cast out to
dinner and i kept saying no
because i didn't what did wasn't
interested and i just wanted to go work
in my
in my uh hotel room and so one day you
said to me no have you ever had a
massage
and i said no i've never had one i say
that sometimes
in college when i saw a girl on the bus
i liked i tried that line
one little massage mace is very painful
it burns the eyes the nostrils
when he was saying massage was he
offering him a science no no what he was
saying was at his hotel there was a good
masseuse there
and the the masseuse place the place to
get the massage was in the gym
and so i i made an appointment but i
didn't tell him what time my appointment
was but he said to me
if if i'm working out and i happen to be
finished with my workout after you're
done with your massage maybe we can like
go get some dinner and i was like yeah
sure whatever
that's not happening right um kind of
like that just like that
and guys love it when women do that to
them
[Music]
but when i got out of the massage place
he was like ooh huh that was a tough
workout
i want to go out today's wearing a white
tuxedo
i was lifting this rose over my head
maybe you would like it
and later on he told me that he had
planned the whole thing i thought you
were gonna say that you showed up for
the massage
and then he was like the masseuse with a
bad mustache
i am antonio bacon
you have um how many you have uh you had
children very young
so you have teenagers now i do i seem
very young to have teenagers
i feel very young teenagers um my son is
17 he's actually going to be 18
next week and my daughter is 15 and you
know i
feel like i should be hip and happy with
everything that's going on i mean i
remember being a teenager just like
yesterday right and but there's a couple
of things i don't get like i don't get
the texting thing
yeah they text everything now do you
think do you text a p are you good at it
i text and i try to be in with a lingo
like lol like i always assumed lol was
lots of love so like i'll text them and
say
i'm so proud of you lol
[Laughter]
i really like that it sort of goes with
your you know talking to kevin oh yeah
i'd love to go to dinner
then your child i just got a message
from my mom i love you so much
laugh out loud
sucker wow but i try
you know but the other thing i don't get
is grinding do you know this
you know grinding grinding what do you
mean grinding it's a dance
but it's it's really strange and
different from when i was a kid i mean
the grinding what they do now is they
they grind which is that
the guy stands up and the girl turns
around
they're not facing each other at all the
girl turns around and
grinds her butt into the guy's
front and to me it's really confusing
because i'm like they don't really know
each other they're not even looking at
each other and yet they're doing this
sort of
very quickly whatever are they
[Music]
simulating
but you know you know what i don't know
why she would be there and he would be
there
no i know i wait here's the thing is
what does that have to do with dancing
in my day we did the charleston you know
we
we did that
but in my day we did the eighth grade
two step what's the eighth grade two
steps can i show you yeah yeah yeah
what's the eighth grade two step
give me a little what like stairway to
heaven or something yeah that's good
something you know something eighth
[Music]
i grady oh more there's more there's
more oh then if we got really close it
was like this oh okay all right
i'm gonna halfway i want naked to come
out and put acne on me so that we can
and my pants would be about here that's
pretty much what it would be like if
we're going to be accurate about this
my pants would be here my belt would be
here
and i'd be going like this with you you
know it would be really bad and then
i'll turn around for
[Applause]
do you guys remember the eighth grade
you guys remember don't ask them about
the eighth grade
these guys grew up fast for the eighth
grade i think we all did that
but kids grow up so fast these days it's
terrible grinding is confusing
don't you think it's confusing it's not
confusing i understand what's happening
uh but yeah it does feel like yeah
that's not a that's not an appropriate
dance i wouldn't allow that
i have two little i have two little
children now no they're gonna learn the
the charleston they're gonna i'm gonna
teach them
i'm gonna teach them dances from the
1880s
my daughter's gonna wear a hoop skirt
they're gonna churn butter
and exactly that yeah exactly the whole
night the boy's gonna wear a chastity
belt i'm telling you
i've got some ideas here
you